hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in politics book 1 aristotle provides a
now-infamous but rather limited defense
of what he calls natural slavery in
which some people would be slaves by
nature meaning that they ought to be
slaves or that it makes sense for them
to be slaves to be in relations where
power is exercised upon them arbitrarily
and they don't have any autonomy or
decision-making capacity in how they're
going to live their lives now in point
of fact this part of Aristotle's
politics was indeed used or rather
abused by people who wanted to justify
slavery in a much broader sense than
Aristotle himself would have
countenanced as we shall see when we
look at the passages what I have in mind
here would be the justification in the
Confederate States of America and prior
to that within the United States of
Antebellum chattel slavery enslaving
people from Africa then it was also used
as a justification in South America to
justify enslaving indigenous inhabitants
but as we'll see much of that would have
been considered illegitimate from
Aristotle's point of view let's talk
about what a slave is from Aristotle's
perspective first before looking at the
question of whether slavery could be
justified so the slave is in greek
Doulos and you can translate that in a
variety of ways sometimes people want to
soften it by saying servant or that
there's other sorts of things a member
of the household client but one of the
things that is missing there is the lack
of inability to exit that relationship
if somebody is merely a servant then
they could leave of course if they're
indentured servant and that then they
can't but a regular servant could leave
and go somewhere else the slave is in
in Aristotle's point of view a piece of
property akka Tama property like books
or oxen or doors or pick whatever else
you like
and as a piece of property the slave can
be bought and sold they have a monetary
value probably a rather subjectively
determined one but as a piece of
property they are being treated not as a
person but as a thing and we might think
of different types of property for
example bits of technology other tools
animals and then we have living human
property slaves the other thing that's
even more important is that the slave
Aristotle stresses is a tool an organ
owned and tool is a very broad word in
Aristotle's work as a matter of fact
some of his books are actually called
the organ on the great tool for logic
right here's another tool this is the
the tool of tools the hand which
operates other tools and the slave is a
special kind of tool how are they
different than other things they're not
merely a living tool they are a tool
with a soul and and this implies not
just that they have life or awareness
but that they have a certain capacity
for thinking things through that have to
be done in their tasks sometimes at a
much higher level sometimes at a much
lower level depending on what their
tasks are and Aristotle actually
suggests that if we had tools that could
run themselves for example a loom in
which the shuttle would weave back and
forth by itself looms and shuttles are
very important in ancient times because
they were the way in which you
manufactured cloth which you need for
all of your clothing you either had to
get cloth from somebody else or you had
to manufacture it at home and it was a
time-consuming task and it required
certain tools to be in place in order to
process the raw materials you might
delegate
leave to be carrying that task out and
if you could in fact have a piece of
technology that operated itself there
would in fact be no reason to have a
slave doing that to devote that person
and their intelligence and their hours
to that task so a slave is a is a tool
that functions within the household to
make certain things possible a slave is
a tool that conduces to not just living
but living well one of the key questions
is how much they enjoy of that in the
household and the answer of course
varies considerably but it's never going
to be as much as the free members of the
household so one of the key questions
then that Aristotle is going to ask is
is anyone a slave by nature and why is
this important this by nature it implies
that if a person is a slave by nature it
is good for them to be a slave or it
makes sense for them to be a slave they
may in fact have no capacity to be
anything other than that so freeing them
could be a major problem because they
would inevitably either fall into
something worse than slavery or go back
to slavery if that's the case and that's
one of the key questions being asked the
other question he asks that's related to
this that helps out in illuminating this
for Aristotle is is it ever useful or
profitable or however you want to put it
some Pharaon in Greek is it ever useful
or is it just is it right dekai owned
for any person to be a slave now why is
he asking these questions here is where
we should think about ancient culture it
was not the case that everybody in
ancient times thought that slavery was
a-ok as
matter-of-fact Aristotle doesn't name
them by name but he brings up a number
of people who say that slavery is
against nature that it's never good that
it's never useful or just for people to
be slaves
so he's considering what in his time is
really a live question there were of
course many other people who said it is
you know good for people to be slaves
and as we're gonna see as we look at it
there's people who kind of hedge
back-and-forth and there are probably
some people who said I don't really care
go just go do your work okay but these
are important questions so I think it's
best to begin by looking at the
arguments put forward by the people who
say that slavery is unjust or against
nature in every case or at least in some
cases so he goes on this is in book one
he says it's not difficult to see that
those who assert that slavery is not by
nature are right in a certain fashion
their right to a certain degree he says
the fact is the term slavery and slave
are ambiguous we think of them as one
thing but they actually named different
relations different things and some of
them may be quite unnatural so he says
there is such a thing as a slave or a
man that is in slavery by law law as a
sort of agreement under which things
conquered and war are said to belong to
their conquerors they says this
conventional this this legal the word
for law here by the way is Nomos which
can mean law or custom so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a law on the
books it could be something that is a
custom of a particular people part of
their culture he says this conventional
right is actually denied or attacked by
many legal ideas just as a state's
person is impeached for proposing an
unconstitutional measure they say that
just because somebody is strong enough
to use force against another
and that doesn't mean that they should
thereby but you know by being an object
of aggression or a prisoner be turned
into a slave that seems quite irrational
quite arbitrary and as in point of fact
Aristotle will point out there's many
people who appear to not be natural
slaves that got swept up in some dragnet
and turned into slaves in the process
and that was illegitimate in his view so
he says that one reason why this this
might be attacked is that in a certain
manner virtue when it obtains resources
has in fact great power to use force and
the stronger power always possesses
superiority and something that's good
so it's thought by many that force
cannot be devoid of goodness but that
doesn't really get to the heart of the
issue then does it the fact that the
person who engages in aggression and
captures people and turns them into
slaves may be good in some sense doesn't
mean that that act of turning them into
slaves or selling them or keeping them
as slaves is indeed good justified or
even useful we can think of many other
examples that Aristotle doesn't go into
but of which he was quite aware namely
debt slavery in ancient times not only
in ancient Greece but in many other
places you could become a slave because
your parents had to sell you because
they were settling debts that they had
sometimes people would even themselves
sell themselves into slavery so as to
pay back all or part of their debts this
is something that goes on today by the
way in the illegitimate instances of
slavery that we still see here in in the
modern era so debt slavery would also be
by Nomos by law or by custom but there's
nothing to say that that would be
legitimate Aristotle goes on and he says
somebody might say that and
of prisoners is just but they might also
deny the assertion they could say that
Wars could be unjust in their origin
nobody who doesn't deserve slavery can
really be a slave and they might also go
on and make a distinction an
ethnocentric distinction that Aristotle
has no problem with between Greeks and
barbarians which means everybody else
and say that well you know enslaving
Greeks not a good thing but enslaving
barbarians that that could be all right
and we could think of many other
instances where people have said these
sorts of things so he talks about them
saying that Greeks themselves have taken
prisoners shouldn't be slaves but
barbarians are and he says what this
leads us to why is this important what
this leads us to is some sort of
principle if they're going to say
something like that they need a
criterion by which to say some people do
in fact deserve to be slaves if they're
captured but other people don't what
could such a criterion B what would
justify enslaving some people but not
enslaving others so one possibility he
says is the difference between virtue
and vice the virtuous person shouldn't
be a slave the vicious person should and
you know if you have households and
people you know bringing their children
up presumably the virtuous are gonna
generate virtuous children and the
vicious are gonna generate vicious
children now Aristotle of course says it
doesn't really turn out like in many
instances where a virtuous person will
have children and those children turn
out completely vicious and vice versa
so that's not it so what could be a
justification and he's discussed this a
little bit earlier he says that what
could justify slavery as natural as
something that is in accordance with
nature is several things you would need
to have somebody who is a natural slave
now what would make a person naturally
be in such a state where
it's better for them to be a slave than
to be free for Aristotle it has to do
with this rational part of the human
soul or mind being either undeveloped or
being underdeveloped it's developed to
the degree that it can at least listen
to reason on the part of somebody else
who actually does understand things but
it's not developed to the point where
the person can conduct their own affairs
in a way that is not going to get them
into some sort of trouble that's not
going to lead to problems children are
like this when they are young but they
develop out of that unless they become
the kind of people who Aristotle would
say would be natural slaves so for the
natural slave who has not developed
those rational capacities it is in fact
advantageous to them to be under
somebody else's guidance somebody else's
rule to not get to decide for themselves
what to do with their earnings or their
time or whether they go from place to
place
or perhaps even over their own sexuality
there's another key component that is
absolutely necessary here that often
gets left out in the abuses of this
let's assume that there are natural
slaves you do not have a slave by nature
unless that person is also under a
natural master they are a slave by
nature in a way but it's not really
advantageous to them to be under anybody
whatsoever I mean it could be that the
person who owns them is actually a
natural slave and they just happen to be
in the right position in some elite and
they can't manage their own affairs well
and then they screw up the slaves
affairs as well a natural master would
have to be somebody who is fully
rational who has self-control who either
has or is on the way to developing the
moral virtues especially prudence which
is required to make sense out of
decision
that we need to make regarding ourselves
and regarding others and our households
without a natural master you don't
really have slavery by nature or in
accordance with nature now the question
is open how many of these natural
masters are there out there
Aristotle doesn't discuss that but
that's well worth considering so if it's
going to be natural slavery Aristotle
says the rule needs to be the best
option for both of them obviously for
the master it's nice to have a slave but
it has to be advantageous for the slave
or else it's not really you could say
good or just or natural slavery it
becomes slavery against nature
so Aristotle's defense of slavery here
is quite a bit more limited than many
people assume honestly many instances of
slavery not only in later history but in
his own time would be viewed by him as
illegitimate as unjust as dis
advantageous for the people involved as
unnatural so we now see what the
conditions are for natural slavery and
we can think about whether they're ever
in fact met
you